we off the great great great what is
this hood [ __ ] like the the face that's
his thing he'll he'll cover up his face
in a mask can't gets Kanye yeah
sane people don't do that well he's not
he's you know he's he's definitely like
like different so and I'm I'm just a
simple servant of of God I'm I'm not a
math I hear you you said White lives
matter
because I think you I'm gonna put words
in your mouth you understood that
they're trying to demonize white people
to create a crisis and for us to fight
with each other I thought that was very
true I think all lives matter but he
went even stronger and said White lives
matter you got criticized for that can
you elaborate on that
yeah I thought that I I thought that
that was my right I felt that I I just
exercised rights that are only uh given
to whites a white person can wear a
t-shirt that says black lives matter but
for a black person to wear a t-shirt
that says white lives matter that
somehow makes me racist so I love just
going up and saying hey what do you
think about this what about that and if
we don't use if we don't use our
Consciousness they're trying to beat us
into our Consciousness and make us
ignorant he's not he's not he's not
wrong in this like I agree they are
trying to dumb us down they are trying
to control us and I think in the white
lives matter instance of him and um
Candace Owens wearing that t-shirt
together I think it was fantastic and I
think it was so provocative I agree you
know and there was no no hatred in it no
nothing and they'll say they'll
attribute hatred to it so he's right and
some of the things he does I'm so on
board with but I just cannot cannot get
behind this anti-Semitism and if he
thinks that Hollywood is controlled by
evil Jews that doesn't mean we should
hate all Jews and we talk about this all
the time with the Islams in you know
with the Muslims in the Islam Community
like how we were always taught that you
know Muslims or the only thing we knew
about Muslims was that you know they
were terrorists and learning more that
you know over a quarter of the Earth's
population is Muslim these people are
not all terrorists it's just Fanatics
who are terrorists who happen to be
Muslim and if these people in you know
the Jewish people that I know in
Hollywood personally these are not
monsters they're freaking nice people
they're regular people that happen to be
really good at the business that they're
in and it bothers me and I'm sure there
are evil ones that I don't know there
are evil people in every industry and
every at every level from the top of the
food chain down to down to bums in the
street so it's frustrating when he I'm
just he's really bothering me with that
and and he's bothering
everybody's music before no just that
one song Gold Digger that we were
talking about I like that song a lot
okay
yeah no I don't listen I may have
listened to Kanye's songs and not even
known that it was Kanye you made
graduation he made graduation so it's
it's all good all right let's just keep
going I'm probably the lowest IQ here of
everyone speaking and I'm saying say out
loud what we feel we would no longer be
ran by the idea of fake influence in
celebrities I did yeah I'm gonna
interrupt you oh no no hold on Alex
don't interrupt me I didn't know I
denounced every celebrity I denounced
every celebrity I ever stood next to God
bless you and you know that's the
Christian word of what I really want to
say any celebrity only celebrity that I
rock with is Ray J literally every every
one of y'all others y'all all song come
see me when y'all want to see me every
fake gangster so-called killer any
basketball player any rapper any actress
any musician any model any editor come
see me come see God's child right now
please I want it I want I want to see my
mama you know what I'm saying you can't
you can't touch in Jesus name that's
right you're not Hitler you're not a
Nazi you don't deserve to be called that
a demonized well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also every human being has something of
value that they brought to the table
especially Hitler how about that one
they want to separate and confuse the
Christians and make us afraid to stand
next to each other a Christian can stand
next to anyone we can go visit R Kelly
in prison we can go talk to Harvey
Weinstein that's what Jesus did yes
because Jesus can save everyone you know
you put on the whole armor of God and
they will not be able to break your
spirit okay so I played those clips in
its entirety because I realized oh it's
a reaction God damn it oh wait no it's
not no there's more to it I I like what
he just said there and I and I I say
that and I believe that that all people
have good things in them no it's weird
that you can't say that because it's
obviously I mean it sounds like insane
to say and it's probably something you
shouldn't even like so you're not
supposed to talk about on the internet
but like obviously like those evil
people did like some good things like
Hitler save dogs like you said he loved
dogs he was a vegetarian because he
loved animals and so he didn't eat
animals but he killed Jews Like that's
weird but he was a sick sick son of a
[ __ ] also you know who tortured and
killed people and used them for medical
experiments and that's wild those
medical experiments did yield some uh
you know I guess good Revelations but
I'd rather have gone without them but
I'd rather go without the medical uh
discoveries and not torture people but
but everybody people were complex if I
listen to Kanye there though I don't see
him as like promoting being a Nazi he's
promoting like love everyone not like
you know he's just really promoting love
everyone and he's taking it to like the
extreme that nobody else does and then
that's why he gets called right but what
is with the squash that he put up on
Twitter last week yeah I'm like what
that's where I struggle because I look
at Kanye and I'm like he is talking like
a man of God like a man who follows
Jesus and when he is saying yes sit with
your enemies talk to everybody get in
the conversation look for the good in in
a human being because that's what Jesus
did and that's what he taught us to do
yeah no I thought this is not just
demonize somebody and cancel them for
the one mistake they made I thought the
same thing about the swastika because
like obviously I know it used to mean a
sign of Peace but my take on the
swastika was similar to like the cons
like the Confederate flag one so like
the people who wear the Confederate flag
and [ __ ] and they're like this is my
Heritage and I'm like but I feel like
you know the connotation with the
Confederate flag is just is slavery so
even if it meant something else before
what everyone thinks of when they see it
is slavery so it's that's how I felt
with the Kanye thing I was like I know
it used to mean a sign of Peace but then
it became so massly adopted as like the
Nazi symbol that I think that that was
kind kind of weird but I I see what like
what he was doing but I just what was he
doing because it could help me to
understand because I haven't been able
to to wrap my head around it or even
imagine what he might have been trying
to accomplish and even anything Elon
Musk who I generally agree with I agreed
with him again on that situation like uh
nobody no you're not having that like if
somebody came into my house and sat at
my kitchen table and I just watched it I
was like it's a sign of Peace he'd be
like it started you know [ __ ]
slapping swastika stickers on all my
guests I'd be like listen pal no get
that [ __ ] out of here or you're getting
the hell out of here one or the other or
both no yeah right so anyway I had to
explain it to me because I I need to
understand I mean I think we could just
keep watching and maybe see more of his
um his takes but I think he was just
posting it as like as the sign of Peace
even though that's not with like the
mass did you hear or read anything well
he kept saying like like he kept talking
about peace and loving everyone so what
else would he be talking about he's not
saying that to kill all Jews but he but
he week or two before that had posted
some sort of I'm gonna go
um like I'm gonna go ape [ __ ] or
something that wasn't that word but
basically I'm gonna go ape [ __ ] on these
Jews like you know what and then you
post swastika knowing fully well the
swastika has even I think an even
stronger in your face connotation for
what it means than than the Confederate
flag because the Confederate flag like I
can at least look at it and say there
was an entire you know culture Southern
Culture around that that wasn't all
about slavery like where the swastika
was completely all the people 20 million
people that died in that war for what
keep going on G God okay bent tonight on
the platform because I don't agree with
someone that doesn't believe in Christ
saying you're cool you're cool you're
cool not you and this is my friend right
this is my boy but we can agree to Chris
agree right but it's still his platform
it's up to him but also I'm not a person
that's gonna say hey I agree with
everything there's things that I said
today that you guys don't agree with
because you're not in the same place or
in the same position in your walk that
I'm at I'm in a position where I love
the person who the doctor that had
plastic surgery on my mom I always have
been in a way where it's I can't hate
huh interesting stuff for sure well
listen a lot of our videos we're talking
about Christianity Christianity and
Islam and religion and I think that for
me anyway like a lot of what I do now it
kind of goes through that filter so to
to just touch on that it reiterate again
and finalize with like looking at Kanye
and what he's going through as it on his
journey as a human being I think we can
we can say let's try to look at him
through the lens of kindness and
understanding I don't think he's all bad
I know he's not in fact I just I just
can't understand some of the things that
he's trying to accomplish or maybe his
maybe he needs some marketing help with
his messaging well he made graduation so
whatever that means yeah
I'm hurting I don't know what to say
what to say hey yes it's about damn time
now we turn the page
[Music]